Film Courage: We're going to test
the story that you're coming up
with from the Story Engine with
the 36 dramatic situations and
Enneagram and various things. I’m
wondering should we name this protagonist?
Jeff Kitchen, Dramatist / Author
/ Founder / Consultant: For me
that would be premature because it's so
explosively open-ended at this point.
One of my favorite points in the development of
a story is the point where the sky's the limit,
like any this this story, there's dozens
of possible stories in this and I want to
like play on the lava like Superman
playing in lava, like just revel in the
open-ended possibilities rather than starting to
consolidate and the name at one from one point of
view is like a detail but I don't want to restrict
any of the apertures in this at this point
because the automaton could be male it could
be female it could be a deity of a sort that lives
inside a machine and presents as one robot but it
really isn't just that there's so many wildly
open-ended possibilities that I would prefer to
arrive at that detail a little bit later fair
enough okay so we have your book here correct
yes okay and this is just the list of the
36 dramatic situations great and it's just
it was created in the 1700s by an Italian
playwright named Carlo Gozzi it was endorsed
by Goethe and Schiller and on the strength of
those endorsements hung around for 150 years or
something until George Polti turned it into a
book [Thirty-Six Dramatic Situations] in 1916.
and it says that basically you can describe any
story quite completely with these 36 dramatic
situations like pursuit disaster falling prey to
cruelty or misfortune revolt daring enterprise
their elements and you can describe any story
quite completely from one point of view with
the 36 dramatic situations in the same way that I
can describe this table quite completely from one
point of view with the periodic table of elements
so this table is carbon hydrogen oxygen magnesium
and so from one point of view you
can describe it quite completely and
so let's see what I'm seeing here so supplication
asking or begging for help is interesting because
if we have an automaton and the need to
steal something and a death or a medicine
and there might be treachery involved so could
the automaton be asking or begging for help is
the automaton being asked asked or begged
for help it's interesting and at this point
it all just goes into the cauldron which is just
like a bunch of bubbling ideas that we're trying
to in which we're trying to create life in a
certain way so deliverance rescuing or being
rescued it seems like that's what this
story would be about in a number of ways
you know an attempt at a rescue it can
be a physical rescue an emotional rescue
but a deep strong need for something like
that then there's crime pursued by vengeance
has something been done that either is
a crime or can be perceived as a crime
for which vengeance has sought and crime pursued
by vengeance is very context sensitive because
someone might take personal affront to something
that is quite harmless but they see it as a crime
against them and their all flared up about it
where other people would be like that's nothing
so it's very perception sensitive of who sees
what as a crime yeah and there's all varying
degrees of crime but it indicates that something's
been done wrong and something substantial has to
be done about it which fits in a story with these
elements vengeance taken for kindred upon kindred
it's infighting getting even with your dad for
beating up your mom for your mom upon your dad
the infighting is interesting it suggests
possibilities and could certainly be active
especially if there's like a large
corporation with competing interests
and infighting and opposing ethics
or something like that pursuit
very much so like in pursuit of something
especially if you're dealing like with a medicine
or something like that like the need to
cure something but also being pursued by
is this robot trying to achieve something
and there's other people trying to stop that
from happening so pursuit could certainly be
active in all of this disaster number six is
it's certainly suggests possibilities
that would be inherent in this idea
and disaster can be like the end of the world
all the way down to a bad hair day so it's
varying it's and it's again perception driven
because somebody on Beverly Hills getting their
poodle fur color the wrong shade of pink can
be like a world-ending disaster for that person
so it again is like what is
perceived as a disaster so the robot
might have to prevent a disaster
and if that robot does that
then one party in that story might perceive the
robot saving everything as a huge disaster in the
same way that everybody cheers when World War II
ends except Adolf Hitler for him it's a massive
disaster for everybody else it's like thank God
we finally beat them that thing falling prey to
cruelty or misfortune if you're like ordering an
AI to do something that goes against its ethics
then it's like why me why am I how did I end up
being put in this position I hate that I have to
harm somebody or disappear
something or steal something or
just falling prey to cruelty or misfortune
is pretty self-evident now revolt is quite
interesting a rebellion and that could be
like what's going on with the antagonist
it could be the the and the android the
automaton the robot could be leading a
revolt it can be a secret revolt it can
be a global revolt it can be a boardroom
revolt where there's only two people involved and
that'll influence the trajectory of the company
is this automaton unexpectedly
turning into a Robin Hood or something
and revolt was absolutely at the core
of Blade Runner where the replicants
are trying to undo their four-year
lifespan daring enterprise doing
something bold and adventurous goes along
with rebellion if you're in that context but
it's interesting in terms of looking
at it looking at an automaton who is
programmed and probably imbued with a certain
personality and character to have a situation
force this robot to violate their program
and become more adventurous more daring
and they may not learn that until
the end or that may be something
they have to do early on but it's an
intriguing it's an intriguing thing
abduction abduction kidnapping or like
psychologically taking control of someone
is intriguing and interesting the enigma the
riddle the mystery if this robot is being told
to accomplish something and yet the robot suspects
the ethics of the person who gave that command
then the riddle of like isn't this wrong or why
is part of me like no it's wrong and part of me
knows I have to do it and doesn't question it at
all so is it like potentially the formation of
a conscience in a robot that was designed to not
have one even if it's like a perfect warrior that
like you say kill that it just kills that but if
it begins to grow a conscience because of the way
it's being tortured by its master or whatever like
you have to violate your ethics to achieve my goal
then as part of the robots like
absolutely and part of the robot's psyche
I didn't even know I could question that
and I can't let my master know that but
part of my brain is like something's
wrong with this so the enigma like
what's really going on who's really up to what and
then the internal mechanics of the automaton like
why am I even asking these questions and I'm the
least suited person to sort out the ethics of this
situation because I was designed without ethics or
I was designed with nothing but ethics part of me
is supposed to think everything through challenge
everything deeply and try to do the right thing
you can see how it's like wildly open-ended
and I'm just playing with possibilities
and it's kind of like what will happen is like
which of these jump out and grab me by the throat
the most that's probably what will emerge as
the elements with which to form the premise
obtaining is pretty straightforward all
different types of people are trying to obtain
stuff animosity between can infighting would be
natural in this type of thing rivalry between
kinsmen competitiveness murderous adultery
possibly because we're dealing with a death
and so death can certainly come with adultery and
that might be something that's confusing to an
Android I don't know madness is quite interesting
because this type of situation seems to infer that
somebody's definitely cracked
and has a substantial agenda
that is contrary to a lot of normal societal
moral values but is the robot going crazy
does the robot need to go crazy to assert
autonomy the situation can be madness
we have fetal imprudence doing something unwise
which can have fatal consequences but it doesn't
have to be literally fatal the less the less
literally you take these situations the more
use you can get out of them so fatal imprudence
could be just saying something to your spouse and
you're like oh I shouldn't have said that now here
she'll be pissed off all day and it's not like
anything ended but it was fatal for the mood that
day so it is all varying degrees of everything
but an automaton that is programmed to execute
with an extreme degree of capability and all that
might still almost intentionally
push the wrong button
and set in action a set of things
that could be fatal to the antagonist
even if part of the robot is like don't push the
wrong button and the other and it just does it
where it's like it's fighting itself so
madness inside the robot potentially too
and fatal imprudence slaying of a kinsmen
unrecognized literally that means like you
stab somebody in the dark and find out later it
was your brother but it can also be like someone
metaphorically feeling slain and unrecognized
like a dad comes home drunk and his his little
girl comes running out and says hey daddy and the
dad is really out of it and it's like I don't know
leave me alone and the little girl feels slain and
unrecognized I'm his little darling he never did
that to me before I really feel slain so there's
so much metaphoric flexibility in that but the
idea of like an automaton always being treated a
certain way by a master and then the master says
I know you've been programmed to do this
all the time but today you have to do this
and the robot could be like what why did you
tell me to do that like he knows what I've been
programmed for I'm an artist I'm a what I'm I'm
a top medical researcher could be anything but
I was designed to save lives and he just told
me to poison somebody it's like I feel slain
and unrecognized so there's possibilities like
that self-sacrifice for an ideal the robot could
be faced with that self-sacrifice for kindred
to save others all sacrificed for a passion
it's interesting it reminds me of data in
Star Trek who was rigorously perfect in
logic and all these things and yet one of his
deepest hungers was to know what it felt like
to be human or to get a joke or something like
that because he was like that doesn't make any
sense why are you laughing what is laughter
so all sacrificed for a passion like data's
hunger to be human could lead him to sacrifice
some parts of some mission to get a chance to
experience what it's like to be a human for
an hour or something like that so this robot
if it's really caught in a really intense
dilemma could make certain key choices that
violate its programming break it out of
certain things open up new possibilities
the necessity of sacrificing loved ones yeah
that could be what the robot is faced with
doing and it can go both ways does the maker of
the robot have to sacrifice the robot to achieve
his or her and adultery I don't know crimes of
Love discovery of the dishonor of a loved one the
finding out you've been betrayed interesting
like the robot discovers that the master has
betrayed them or the master discovering the robot
didn't obey orders obstacles to love is certainly
inherent in there and enemy loved that's really
interesting because that means not just falling in
love with an enemy which happens but also respect
for an enemy or fascination with an enemy and so
if the robot is caught between like the
commands of its master and the Intriguing
aspects of like a rebel leader who somehow
begins interacting with this automaton and
has a fascinating argument the robot may
find itself fascinated by this enemy and
respecting the enemy maybe even growing
to love the values that the enemy brings
to the table and yet knowing full while
but that I shouldn't even be talking to
this person much less incorporating some
of their values into my operating system
ambition absolutely clearly if there's like a
master of this robot who has vast Ambitions and
maybe a huge corporation and like if they
can cheat this one thing then you go from
being a hundred billion dollar Corporation to a 10
trillion dollar Corporation and they're willing to
do whatever it takes and the robot could be
caught in the middle of all that and the robot's
Ambitions like we were talking about data wanting
to be human and one of the things here was um
what was it it means giving up their dream like
that speed like what dream might a robot have
um and this this robot could have been to Jupiter
20 times like seeing the whole solar system like
been on fire on the surface of mercury and been
rebuilt and like all it wants to do is like curl
up with a good book in front of a fire or lay
on the beach like it's like it once it's done
all the the most incredible stuff it just wants a
simple little cozy moment they talk about that in
tibetan mythology about how the gods often want
to become human they're sick of being all wise
all-knowing all seeing and they just want to be
immortal and have like a little house and a white
picket fence and be finite and not know everything
which is where data was coming from in a certain
way and this character could certainly be doing
that so ambition is explosively active in a whole
bunch of possible ways conflict with a god Works
in two key ways that I see right off the bat like
the automaton is in conflict with its Commander
its boss and there's conflicting commands that
stuff confusing commands commands that can't be
obeyed but must be and I've often thought the
with Robbie the robot he says Robbie's like
and he really can't fire but he can't not fire
and he releases him from the command he
says if I leave him like this he'll melt
down but the model that I work with in terms of
dramatizing a story is you put your protagonist
in a good strong dilemma similar to like Jake in
Training Day where he can't let go of this amazing
opportunity to make alonso's Squad his ambition he
can't let go of his ambition but he can't go down
the slippery moral slope that Alonso is leading
him on because it's more and more criminality and
risk and danger so he can't let go of his
ambition but he can't let go of his moral compass
and then that dilemma comes to a critical
juncture when Alonso tries to have him killed
in the bathtub By the Hillside gang members and
once he gets out of that he makes a decision about
his dilemma which is I'm taking Alonso down no
matter what and his action is to go in there and
try to arrest him and so I often thought that it's
almost an interesting analogy if you could get to
that robot that is short-circuiting and it's like
it really can't send a command in either direction
and I don't know what the best way to say it is
but override the operating system and tell the
robot you must decide now and like it is it
going to blow up is it what's it going to do
but it's like when push comes to shove
could you make that short-circuiting robot
arrive at some decision from within its
programmed architecture that type of thing
and take some action which fits
which which relates to this story
because we potentially have a robot that's really
melting down between two unacceptable commands two
commands that cannot neither one can be obeyed
but must be obeyed he can't disobey orders but
he can't harm a human being and Robbie the
robot so conflict with a God is interesting
the robot is up against its creator its master and
yet and that is presumably the antagonist although
not necessarily and yet could this Commander
be up against this robot that is Godlike
in its capacity and in its linkage or hidden
linkage to all the capabilities of this massive
manufacturing facility like Hal or something
like that where there's tremendous capability
so going up against this robot can be risky and
you're up against all the the Fail-Safe mechanisms
mechanisms that you built into the robot as you
try and outwit it or defeat it or overpower it
erroneous judgment making a bad choice the robot
could make a bad choice the master there could be
key wrong choices remorse the robot could grow to
have remorse which it didn't used to have the boss
could have absolutely no remorse the recovery of
a lost one gaining something back that's been lost
or attempting to gain a person that's been
lost even bring someone back from the dead
um if if there's a key death in this story
and we saw that in iRobot with Will Smith
that the character played by James Cromwell was
killed at the beginning of the story and yet the
Will Smith characters interacting with a hologram
of the James Cromwell character who's trying
to give him Clues but it was all pre-recorded
before James cromwell's death so he keeps saying
if you want an answer to that you
asked to ask the right question
so it was all in there but he couldn't access it
until he figured out what the right question was
if someone died like say the boss who's trying to
make the robot do a certain thing maybe is the son
of the person that actually built the robot and
the father recently died and now this the sun
inherits command of the robot's operating
system and is doing things that are counter
counter to what the father would have done and
yet still fit within that Groove so the robot
still believes it has to obey but it's
like going I I don't like this and so if
the father's elements of the father's
mind or something were computerized or
emulated by computers they did this with expert
systems a classic example was Campbell's Soup
where the guy who'd been in charge of making the
big Vats of soup for 30 years was getting ready
to retire and they they created an expert system
in which he downloaded all his knowledge and all
the variables like if it tastes too salty you put
in cornstarch or whatever like a certain amount
and they basically just debriefed everything he
knew so that a machine could emulate much of
his knowledge and and some of his instincts
so that if some aspect of the master had been
and possibly even secretly because the the
old man knew that his son might go this way so
that he may have been laying preparation so um
the possibility that the robot
is secretly trying to like bring
the original founder back to life to some degree
for guidance or to countermand the order or to
even regenerate the person physically like make a
clone of them and then download a mind into them
these are all just Dynamic possibilities to
play with and you can see how as I'm going
through the 36 I'm trying each one on like
in varying ways and different possibilities
so recovery of a lost one that's where that came
from and then loss of loved ones like maybe the
robot brings the old man back for a while and
that really helps the robot become more human
and have more free will like the like the original
Master might say you can do anything you want
like we programmed all this stuff into you but
you still have tremendous latitude and maybe
I can even go in and undo some of those
deep commands like you can never disobey
maybe that maybe the founder serves
a function at a key moment and then
you know like even if there's like a physical
person in front of him who is the the man maybe
he only lives for 20 minutes so there's still
loss of loved ones but it's enough to like
free the automaton from the perceived
limits that were binding the automaton
it's the the the classic example
that psychiatrists use a lot is
elephants when they're young like a circus
elephant to be restrained is hooked up to
a really strong chain that you could tow a truck
with and into a really big stake in the ground and
it knows it can't get away I mean it tries but as
it grows up it gets so used to being chained that
they just put a little two by two in the ground
with a piece of clothesline and the robot still
is like up that's as far as I can go when the did
I say robot I meant elephant the adult elephant
could could shred that but their they're trained
to that and that could be something similar to
the robot and where the original founder might say
look you you've Incorporated all these habits into
your daily life and you're like the adult elephant
that's still restrained by a piece of clothesline
you you are a creature of tremendous power and
you're capable of anything and don't think small
don't let your program which is perfect metaphor
for people in the real world having tremendous
capability but believing that they're small and
worthless and easily controlled and all that
so that's an interesting element and that
was just from just going through this one
complete spectrum of ideas that can trigger
possibilities and we were looking at each one
of those situations through the lens of
all of these combined in varying degrees
and I really like the and see what it is is that
some of those stuck I said some of them will jump
out and grab me by the throat like I really like
the sun and the father and possibly the father
killed the son and the father had more morals than
the Sun and the son is going to take a corporation
worth 200 billion and make it worth 20 20 trillion
like within three months but he needs the robot
to withhold a medicine or create a disease
create a contagion that the medicine is a
cure for and a billion people die and then
they come up with the Cure and then eight
billion people each spent a hundred dollars on
and all of a sudden this corporation's worth 8
trillion like literally overnight on its way
to being worth 80 trillion a year from now
but who has to die for that
progress and can the robot
deal with the ethics and make a right choice
when it's supposed to just be a robot that just
keeps putting the hubcap on the
new car without anything else
so an automaton who is a perceived as
a servant and a puppet and a machine
like you push the button and it puts the hubcap on
CE to steal or wants to stop the theft
of both of them are interesting because
they they infer two opposite commands
potentially like protect or destroy or
the the founder wants the theft to be
stopped and the new one wants it to
steal or probably more interesting is that
the AI of the founder is recommending to
the robot that it's steel to prevent the
Sun from consolidating this new foreign
and a medicine going hand in hand with a
contagion is interesting in terms of um
manipulating a global uh
you know a global con a death is interesting
because we were talking about how the
founder died and was maybe murdered
even a hospital is interesting because if this
is similar perhaps to the Tyrell Corporation
then a lot of a per a healthy
percentage of the setting could
take place in a hospital-like
corporate manufacturing facility
and all this subterranean access almost hidden
tunnels or underworld aspects that the robot might
be able to incorporate the innocent will suffer
yeah if it's going to take a billion people to die
of this contagion to sell eight trillion dollars
worth of this medicine that they've had for years
then that's that's something the robot has to
wrestle with but it means giving up their dream
well if this robot is designed to be
extremely helpful to humanity altruistic and
yet has been counter programmed to cause
great harm or allow great harm to happen
and yet is stuck in the middle trying to
resolve that dilemma
that could certainly like the robot might
be programmed to be so altruistic that its
dream is to have everyone healthy happy
doing well and it's simplistic but it's
like starting somewhere within the context
of the story we're playing with here uh
like the robot's natural inclination to altruism
is being contravened or corrupted by the Sun
but what's on the opposite side of
that like obviously the sun cares if
they're worth 8 trillion tomorrow
but what does that give the robot
it certainly opens up the possibility for solving
a whole lot more stuff but the sun doesn't seem
to have that natural inclination to use this 8
trillion to solve world hunger almost the opposite
so that's an interesting
means giving up their dream
and it certainly could be that
the robot dreams of being human
dreams of being retired at the end of its
sort of indentured servitude and get to live like
a person for a while or something that may have
been something that was always promised to it or
something and then treachery glorious obviously
the sun could be treacherous but the robot could
be treacherous in what it does to outwit the Sun
and the father could promote that
treachery like you've got to think
around the evil of my son because
if you don't he's going to beat
you you've got to fight dirty to beat
him because all he does is fight dirty
so I feel like I've got more of a handle on a
potential story there I don't feel like I have a
premise yet but I feel like we've cobbled together
something that's interesting and dynamic and has
high stakes and complexity and a
dilemma of magnitude for this automaton
an interesting Ally in the form of the old man a
potential strong villain in the form of the Sun
um so that's a good we've
gotten to a platform here
where we've got something that feels much
more solid than just a open-ended set of
possibilities we've cooked it down a little
bit and have more of a something there.